Guten morgen tim.
Tim.
Aux
Logbuch netz politik nummer drei hundertzweiundzwanzig frisch auf den tisch vom dreißigsten november zweitausendundneunzehn.
Aus dem funkloch oder soll wir sagen aus der netz insel der mieter ebene.
Aus dem sende loch.
Ja ich fand das sehr schön wird das gesagt weil das der meinte wie man sollte nicht von funklöcher sprechen sondern von netz insel weiß,
sozusagen das falsche bild liefert so als würde man sich sowieso netz laufen wo ab und zu meiner karl stelle ist aber es ist ja eigentlich ja.
Genau umgekehrt ja.
So sieht's aus.
Kommen wir auch gleich noch zu.
Wenn ich wäre das nicht mitbekommen hat es war einfach der wunderbare wunderbare tagesschau berichtet,
der halt aus über funklöcher aus meseberg das ist diese dieses schlüsseln da was die bundesregierung im norden von berlin hat.
Für ihren dicker.
Die sind ja schon immer auf detox,
und dann steht dann halt die reporterin da und übertragen natürlich auch mittlerweile alle über früher noch so richtig ihre ü-wagen und richtung und tralala und das war natürlich alles schön teuer weil sie es nicht mehr bezahlen können machen sie dich mit lte läuft natürlich super,
aber halt nicht in meseberg und dann blieb einfach genau im funkloch bericht das bild steht es war schon ja.
Sehr meter.
Mit meter absolut.
Ist ein bisschen feedback müssen wir behandeln.
Ja und zwar hansi hansi viel schreibt uns zu dem zu der frage.
Das instagram ja jetzt diese likes nicht mehr anzeigt ein für instagram,
nein moment entschuldigung in sechs ländern dieser erde gerade einen test betrieb hat,
indem sie die anzahl der likes nicht mehr nach außen anzeigen
ein für instagram netter nebeneffekt des verstecken von likes ist auch das influencer ihre werbung nicht mehr so leicht selbst vermarkten können,
wie angesprochen ist ein screenshot leicht gefälscht und die werbetreibende müssten sich für verlässliche zahlen dann direkt an instagram wenden.
Nicht doof von das ist natürlich ein tatsächlich interessanter aspekt davon.
Hat mir das nicht auch angesprochen.
Ne nicht nicht unbedingt dass es dass es da tatsächlich ein finanzielles interesse auch von instagram geben kann dass,
ich war bei der gelegenheit habe ich mir mal instagram angeguckt der wisst ja verrückt bei,
also instagram hab ich dann hab ich mir angeguckt geht ja überhaupt nicht jeder vierte oder dritte ich weiß jetzt jeder dritte oder vierte war.
Es ist eine litfaßsäule also es ist ich verstehe das auch nicht.
Absolut also macht mich sofort aggressiv sofort aggression gekriegt ganz schlimm ja aber genau danke an sie dann viel.
Trotzdem stehen die leute drauf ich mache mich macht das auch ein bisschen fassungslos muss sagen diese,
ich dachte immer ich weiß auch nicht was ich denke.
Ich habe auch ich habe jetzt auch irgendwie mal bei twitter man irgendwie die webseite benutzt das ja auch überall werbung jetzt weiß ich warum die warum die meine kleines absägen immer am laufenden band und den die abi zu drehen weil.
Ja ja genau deswegen also ich sehe das ja auch nicht ne und und vor allem ich sehe auf twitter immer noch ein chronologischen reinfolge alles wenn du da mal.
Ja das sieht immer gleich aus also ähnlich wie spiegel online.
Keine ahnung schaust ja irgendwie so ein hashtag an und dann kriegst du da so skurrile anordnung soll,
sie am am relevantesten halten aus den letzten tagen und wochen und,
mit antworten chris halt irgendwie gar nichts mehr gebacken aber das gut das ist halt einfach die couragierten timeline.
Ja das ist alles quatsch also aber dass sie das nicht mal das was wir davon haben wenn wir unsere kommunikations infrastruktur.
Wir wissen schon was sie mögen wir wissen schon sie brauchen sich gar keine eigene meinung mehr zu bilden.
Das sind ja auch nicht da damit wir uns meinung bilden die sind da damit wir etwas kaufen charlotte kommentiert.
Kleine korrektur zum ersten feedback thema unter mobilität wird die krankheit häufigkeit verstand.
Habt ihr sie verwechselt mit der mord der sterblichkeit stimmt.
Hallo.
Hammer danke bitte.
Charlotte nicht du tim.
So dann haben wir die reise warnung.
Reise warnung informiert uns feedback zur sendung wo wir über e-motor gesprochen haben.
Schön dass ihr das thema mal ausführlicher erklärt habt interessant gewesen wären noch die begriffes bier fishing und deine might fishing,
die hört man in diesem zusammenhang ja auch häufig schnell erklärt.
Fishing wäre bezeichnet den begriff im prinzip artig nachrichten,
zu versenden also die strategie ist ich verschicke hundert tausende oder hunderttausende solcher nachrichten mit irgendwie einen link drin den leute klicken sollen in der erwartung dass halt irgendwie ein prozent null komma ein prozent oder so,
ich schaffe am filter vorbeizukommen und am anderen ende wenn so,
einfaches opfer zu finden ist das dann auch auf meinen link klickt also ein auf große mengen aufgebautes geschäftsmodell fishing hingegen,
also das speer fischen kennen wir alle lernt man ja in der grundschule mit dem speer fische zu töten wo genau also im gegensatz zu einem
schleppt netz fischen eben der der spezifische fisch ausgewählt wird und wir eine,
fishing nachricht spezifisch an dieser eine person schritt schicken oder an weniger personen dafür aber auch perfekt,
getagt bietet auf sie dass das diese person mit dieser fishing nachricht auf diese fische nachricht hoffentlich reinfällt.
Dynamik fishing ist ein wie ich finde nicht besonders treffender begriff den,
jürgen schmidt der heiße security redaktionsleiter wenn nicht seine rolle der jetzt richtig in erinnerung habe prägt für das was,
eben bei passiert dass eben quasi das fishing erstmal.
Geschieht um in das unternehmen reinzukommen und die nächsten ebenen des fishing sich aber auf diese e-mail,
verkehre die ja am anfang quasi aus dem outlook rausgeholt werden beziehen also es ist da nicht mehr,
es ist ein sehr kontext duales fishing was also was sie angepasst wird an,
das kommunikations verhalten dieser person,
da hat er jetzt den begriff den damit fishing für,
geprägt oder versucht ihn zu prägen ich weiß ich habe ich habe weder döner mit fischen mit das glaube ich verboten,
ja weil man wirft man halt 'n sprengt sprengt objekt ins wasser und durch den durch die explosion platz diese blase die luftblase von den fischen mit der die kontrollieren ob sie oben oder unten schwimmen und dann,
sind sie tot,
ich weiß nicht genau wie jetzt auf den vergleich kommt aber ich glaube deshalb meinst du wenn du einen erwischt hast platz der und tötet alle anderen mit oder so ne das ist wahrscheinlich der,
bezug ja aber damit haben wir die unterschiedlichen begriff form des fishing,
die sich im prinzip daran unterscheiden ist es zielgerichtet auf die seine person oder nicht ja.
Das ist auf jeden fall sehr oft zum einsatz kommen der methode wenn ich das richtig sehe,
zumindest sehr effizient auch.
Ja also das problem daran ist natürlich desto,
kaum noch hinweis reize hast um um das zu erkennen ne also wenn dir würde niemand auf schlechte ideen bringen aber wenn das halt wirklich eine,
glaubwürdige e-mail ist die du bekommst die einem kontext den du erwartest entspricht.
Dann ist es natürlich auch relativ wahrscheinlich dass du entsprechend darauf reagierst.
Übrigens werde ich dazu auch einen vortrag beim kongress halten dürfen ich habe notiz von bekommen dass ich eine kleine ein kleinen slot,
beim beim sechsunddreißig drei über menschliche schwachstellen halten darf ja,
kann ich jetzt endlich mal ein bisschen über das reden was in den letzten jahren ja im beruflichen teil geforscht habe,
ich freue mich wie ein kurzer vortrag,
beim sechsunddreißig drei in leipzig,
so dann haben wir das ich habe das jetzt bei feedback einsortiert das ist aber nicht wirklich feedback ich weiß gar nicht genau ich mach das ja so selten aber ich war bei einer konferenz in berlin mit dem namen,
statt nach acht die konferenz irgendwie über das nachtleben.
Und der war ganz interessant ich dachte eigentlich dass wir ein bisschen kleiner spaß oder so ne da hingekommen aber doch gar nicht so klein die konferenz wie ich dachte.
Und da habe ich an einer an einer panel diskussion teilgenommen was ich sowieso eigentlich nie mache,
aber da hab ich das getan weil ich mich das weil mich das thema tatsächlich interessiert hat zwar ging es so ein bisschen um den kulturkampf von rechts,
wo es also wo ich eingeladen war als jemand der jetzt durch die fusion,
da ein bisschen erfahrung mitgemacht hat welche steine eben auch durch politische oder vermeintliche politische motivation kulturveranstaltung in den weg gelegt werden können,
da waren viele unterschiedliche initiativen auf der bühne aber auch natürlich viele unterschiedliche initiativen,
im publikum und wir haben ein bisschen darüber gesprochen ja wie das so ist auf dem land ne tanzen auf dem acker oder wie hieß die die du dazu gemacht hast mit dem andre.
Party kultur.
Party kultur hieß sie nicht tanzen auf dem acker nee party kultur ne.
Also party machen in brandenburg das machen wir hier in berlin wenn wir rausfahren in die wüste dann also in amerika macht man burning man wir machen,
festivals irgendwo in in brandenburg oder mecklenburg-vorpommern,
zwischen berlin und hamburg und da waren also jetzt,
wie gesagt verschiedene initiativen vor ort und welche die kleinere partys machen dass mir eine aufgefallen nämlich die,
gegen rechts lokal gruppe güstrow.
Güstrow den leuten die die fusion geschichte verfolgt haben das war in güstrow befindet sich die polizei fachhochschule,
an der die arbeit geschrieben wurde diese bachelorarbeit.
Dokumente gelegt worden von der fusion.
Wo die dokumente gelegt worden von der fusion ja und wo der verurteilte gewalttäter.
Polizei fachhochschule lehrer ist ja ehemaliger afd-politiker der für ein gewaltausbrüche,
rechtskräftig verurteilt wurde und dann ja mehr oder weniger straff versetzt wurde an die fachhochschule in güstrow ulf theodor claßen heißt der übrigens ja,
wegen gefährlicher körperverletzung wurde der verurteilt weil er an seinem afd stand protestieren mit pfefferspray angegriffen hat,
in dieser stadt ja macht die rock gegen rechts lokal gruppe güstrow das fest rhythmus gegen rassismus,
und ein kleines konzert mit integrierten familienfest im stadtpark von güstrow finde ich gut.
Und die haben gerade eine spenden kampagne auf betterplace,
mit sehr moderaten mit einem sehr moderatoren budget die wollen da irgendwie so tausendzweihundertfünfzig euro irgendwie zusammenkriegen,
wie vierhundertfünfzig euro für bands vierundfünfzig euro für miete vierhundertfünfzig euro für technik und machen dann eben in güstrow ein familienfest mit musik und tanz und das ist doch wirklich,
was schönes und deswegen würde ich gerne auf deren betterplace crowdfunding aufmerksam machen.
Was wir hiermit getan haben befindet sich in den shownotes.
Zwanzig zwanzig soll das stattfinden er ist so eine schöne sache.
Ja und aus der abteilung leute drin frei.
Ah ja das ist doch auch feedback genau ja aus der abteilung leute drehen frei und andere sind schuld der,
gründer oder eine der amerikaner der englischen leid figuren hier von extension rebellion der roger der ja schon öfter dauert durch aufgefallen ist weniger,
kluge dinge zu sagen,
hat das wieder getan und hat in einem interview,
den holocaust relativ wird.
Am untergang der menschlichkeit der menschheit hat irgendwie sinngemäß etwas gesagt heute der begriff war,
justin factory also der holocaust war irgendwie nur wieder eine kleine scheiße im vergleich zu dem was uns bevorsteht wenn der planet untergeht,
das ist natürlich eine absolut inakzeptabel äußerung,
das hat glaub ich ungefähr fünf minuten gedauert bis irgendwie alle extension in gruppen zumindest in deutschland in großbritannien habe ich das nicht über blickt sich von ihm distanziert haben.
Und das ist natürlich auch richtig so und das ist auch gut so,
interessanterweise haben die detektive der des internets schon festgestellt dass friday it's for future und extension rebellion,
beide auch auf dem sechsunddreißig drei vortragen vorträge halten werden und haben dann sofort gefordert dass jetzt extension rebellieren vom kongress ausgeladen wird.
Klar sigma haft hat mir auch schon mal das thema hier ne.
Hatten wir auch schon und ich muss jetzt meine meinung,
revidieren und meinen beitrag zu deren buch zurücknehmen und hast du alles nicht gesehen ja,
liebe freunde selbstverständlich eindeutig war das niemals die motivation von den deutschen extension rebellieren aktivistinnen
irgendwelche antisemitischen oder bei knacken parolen von ihnen ein briten zu verfolgen die haben sich sofort von diesem spinner distanziert und machen weiter und das ist eben genau der unterschied zwischen einer
aktivistinnen gruppe und sozialen engagement dass es eben nicht an einzelnen führen oder führerscheinen hängt auch wenn wie heißt sie hier jutta dietfurt das gerne so herbei schreibt.
Und jetzt alle schuld sind ja du bist jetzt schon wieder in der neuen konkret ist wieder ein artikel von der über extension belgien ich glaube die kriegt ihr jetzt bald ihre eigene kolumne.
Ja nicht meine sein gewisser hinsicht auch beruhigen dass die dass die bewegung da auch in der in der lage ist relativ schnell stellung zu beziehen so hätte man sich zum beispiel.
Selbstverständlich ist auch völlig affig jetzt irgendwie den leuten zu unterstellen sie hätten sie würden irgendwie so blöden ziele teilen von diesem von diesem helm da aber ironischerweise.
Die piraten auch mal schneller hinkriegen soll am anfang irgendwie das hätten sich einigen ärger erspart.
Ironischerweise handelt davon mein kapitel in deren buch ja wo ich drin schreibe,
wer zu allen seiten offen ist kann nicht ganz dicht sein ja das ist dann eben wiederum ging wir machen hier extension baby und alle können mitmachen und ich so.
Ich weiß schon worüber ich euch mal was schreiben kann.
Hier gerade bittet also spezifisch genau darüber geschrieben.
Dass es probleme geben wird wenn man sich so verhält ja oder wenn man seine organisation oder seine
gruppierung so organisiert naja,
extension in berlin in deutschland machen weiter und ja ist jetzt auch gar kein gar kein anlass.
Dann gab es noch ein todesfall der jetzt nicht unbedingt überraschend kam nichtsdestotrotz trotzdem sehr schade ist,
jimmy schulz ist gestorben ein politiker bei der fdp,
der aber im netz politischen bereich,
sehr aktiv zur debatte beigetragen hat,
und der letzte seit einiger zeit und da krebs das ist ja auch sehr öffentlich geworden zahlreiche,
interviews gab's dazu äußern gestorben.
Ja er war mitglied in der kommission digitale gesellschaft als b hat
dann jetzt seine letzte rolle im bundestag nach der einzug der fdp war
vorsitzender des ausschusses digitale agenda das haben wir hier auch damals noch freudig und wohlwollen zur kenntnis genommen danach wurde still um ihn weilheim dann,
die erkrankung bekannt wurde und ja das war jetzt.
Ja leider leider leider absehbar dass er ein halber krank ist und ich glaube sein letztes interview spiegel,
titelte auch irgendwie es ist in ordnung dass ich sterbe das war jetzt.
Konnten wir uns jetzt längere zeit darauf vorbereiten ist aber trotzdem schade.
Und ähm neben der also neben der menschlichen tragödie wahrscheinlich auch ein politischer verlust der sich unter umständen nicht so einfach wieder wegmachen lässt denn
der mann hatte im format und charakter das ist in der fdp gerade nicht mehr so einfach zu finden,
in anderen parteien auch nicht viel leichter aber das war ein streitbarer,
mensch der sehr viel wert darauf gelegt hat also auf ja auf demokratie dass menschen miteinander reden und diesen wie man in der internet covern es nennt den multi stakeholder ansatz immer sehr.
Und trifft immer die falsche.
Trifft nicht immer die falschen eine ganz gute über,
na ganz gute über leitung denn das fischer hat wieder zugeschlagen,
und da hat man die richtigen getroffen,
wir haben im logbuch schon öfter über veneers fischer gesprochen,
eine person oder gruppe über die man einfach mal gar nichts weiß die zwanzig vierzehn das unternehmen gamma gehackt hat den hersteller,
der schadsoftware finn fischer die von staatlichen organisationen eingesetzt wird.
Und daher auch das unter dem namen veneers fischer getan hat dann zwanzig sechzehn die akp gehackt hat in teilen also die partei von,
erdogan,
im gleichen jahr auch noch hacking team die italienische staatsstraße jana bude beide male sowohl der gamma finn fischer skandal als auch der hacken team skandal dann eben mit entsprechenden leaks in welche.
Staaten und welche,
autoritären regimen die ihre schadsoftware exportieren hacking team gast da noch irgendwie der geschäftsführer hat immer so faschistische grüße gemacht was jetzt in italien,
gibt es ja immer noch einige anhänger des dusche oder wie nennt ihr musst du linie dusche ne.
Ja also für hacking team und gamma jeweils sehr katastrophale folgen team glaube ich existiert auch nicht mehr als unternehmen,
gamma finn fischer existiert noch sehr zum leidwesen mal gucken wie lange das noch dauert,
dann hat er sie es wie ihr sie auch zwanzig sechzehn noch die katalanische polizeigewerkschaft gehackt und dann war es ein bisschen ruhig,
und jetzt hat sich finde es fischer wieder gemeldet hat gesagt ja die letzten drei jahre habe ich mit banken gearbeitet und.
Hat erstmal die.
Ich hab da ein paar konnten eröffnet.
Die national,
bank gehackt und internetdaten extrahieren und jetzt in einem sehr kämpferischen text.
Eine belohnung von bis zu einhunderttausend us-dollar ausgelebt für weitere leaks brisanter unternehmens daten,
hat irgendwie mehrere unternehmen ausgelebt die am krieg gegen roger war verdienen ein hersteller betreiber von privaten gefängnissen bergbau viel und ab holzindustrie,
die wie denn da geschrieben wird unser schönes lateinamerika plündern ja das finde ich natürlich ein bisschen,
mach mir ein bisschen sorge weil sich in dem text dann doch 'ne ganze reihe referenzen,
verbergen die hypothesen erlauben über,
sagen wir mal die muttersprache von fitness fischer bestimmte politische,
gruppierungen besonders anspricht und das als in einem wir,
tut warum macht man das sorgen ja weil das immer eingrenzung sind ne wenn du irgendwie vorher eine person bist die weltweit völlig unbekannt ist,
und man nicht weiß wo kommt die person her schreibt auf englisch.
Äußert sich allgemein aber hier in diesem texten offenbaren sich dann eben,
ja kenntnisse der zap artistischen erklärungen und so ja sitzt
eine überweisung ging da irgendwo in richtung mexiko und so das macht mir sorge dass da jetzt
finger ist fischer leichter face einfließen lässt das wäre echt schade wenn uns dieser wenn uns das irgendwie,
irgendwann mal verloren gehen würde was was wir hier schönes sehen deswegen wurde finde ich es fischer ja auch spezifisch von,
thorsten mir in unserem kongress vortag letztes jahr,
gegrüßt ja dann wäre nochmal ein spezifischen gruß gegeben den tipp zu finden ist fischer weil chinesischer macht das mit der op sehr gut hätten ist einfach nicht erwischt wenn es schwierig und finde es fischern kann auf jeden fall gut hacken und,
bisher auch immer gut nicht erwischt werden.
Ich kann natürlich auch eine eins a nebelkerze sein.
Keine einzelne nebelkerze sein ich hoffe es ich habe keine ahnung und das soll auch so bleiben.
Ich merke schon wasser spaß dran.
Ja auf weiße ne wenn also,
ich sehe da jetzt gerade irgendwie keinen der mit dem ich mitleid haben müsste da haben irgendwie,
zehntausend bitcoin im wert von zehntausend euro irgendwie nach roger war gespendet,
mit unter dem unter der bezahlung hack back das scheint ganz gut,
scheint ganz gut zu laufen das geschäft dafür finde es fischer,
und bisher habe ich ja auch keinen anlass geboten da mal zu den zielperson zugehören,
und ja wer beabsichtigt das kopfgeld von einhunderttausend u s dollar zu kassieren sollte auf jeden fall vorher in die schule gehen damit das ist nicht so einfach,
hunderttausend euro kopfgeld zu kassieren.
Natürlich jetzt wer mal wieder so ein interessanter trend ne so.
Gegen in sozusagen krimineller manier ne also schauen wir jetzt,
rein den gesetzen den meisten gesetzen nach alles extrem strafbar aber halt in so einer robin hood attitüde so wir nehmen's von den reichen und verteilen zu den armen,
da kann man natürlich.
Da kann man natürlich positive assoziationen mithaben ich freue mich aber nur wo wohin das alles noch führen soll.
Das werden wir sehen.
Wahrscheinlich.
Macht darf sich natürlich nicht den dem eindruck hingeben dass hacking jetzt irgendwie eine,
praxis wäre die nur wir oder nur linke oder nur liberale und nur robin hood irgendwie verfolgen das wird genauso von,
kriminellen gemacht und das ist auf jeden fall,
eine gefährliche spielerei die da stattfindet und ein verstoß gegen,
ja sag mal ein milder verstoß gegen die hacker ethik und so weiter aber zunächst einmal auch ganz unterhaltsam.
Ist ja auch vielleicht mal ganz kurz in die vergangenheit zu blicken gibt's ja noch diesen begriff des hektik ja der glaub ich einer der missverstanden,
begriffe ist das kam glaube ich damals auf.
Als die franzosen im pazifik nochmal atom test machen wollten.
Noch so mit jack chira.
Und dann gab 's dann irgendwie hier so fuck und unter anderem dann halt auch so die ersten digitalen,
anwürfe mit ja wenn ihr das nicht unterlasst dann die dosen wir hier irgendwie alle eure server und klicken alles die,
zum zeitpunkt als das internet natürlich noch extrem unter entwickelt.
Also das noch mit dem sechsundfünfzig kam vor dem detoxen konntest.
Ja und da wurde dann halt auch dieser begriff des hektar geboren und der spalte sich auf ein wenig die
die lose hacker sehen ich weiß dass der club damals relativ klar die these vertreten hat dass das irgendwie jetzt kein guter weg ist und man jetzt nicht unbedingt die blockierung von digitalen daten wegen mit sitz blockaden vergleichen kann,
aber seitdem hat die diskussion in dem sinne nicht nicht aufgehört,
da kommt auf jeden fall dieser begriff her und deswegen ist ja auch so vom club niemals so verinnerlicht worden.
Also ich.
Und das das das hier würde ich sagen.
Das wäre wichtiger hektar.
Das ist so richtiger deluxe aktivisten und ja also man kann da halt sagen okay wir sind eine ziele wir sind deine taten daran soll man dich messen,
oder euch ähm.
Aber es ist halt auf jeden fall auch eine eine eskalation jetzt kann man sagen es ist jetzt schon notwehr ist angriff.
Also das hier ist auf jeden fall 'n stil award ja und ich würde mich das nicht trauen.
Und das wir einiges heißen.
Ich auch nicht ja nee also man kann natürlich nur mutmaßen aber es macht so ein bisschen den eindruck also wer so was macht kann jemand sein der sich maßlos selbst überschätzt.
Das kann ich ja auch noch kommen selbst wenn es noch nicht so ist ähm das kann aber auch sein dass man es jetzt wirklich mal so mit jemand aus der abteilung super hero zu tun hat eine person die oder personen die.
Richtige toplevel heil skills haben womit meyer problemlos sehr reich werden kann,
auf die eine oder auf die andere art und weise also womit legaler als auch mit illegaler tätigkeit,
daneben trotzdem so eine politische orientierung sich auf einmal breit macht und sagt so durch,
setzt das jetzt einfach mal für diese zwecke ein das macht ja auch beides was man nicht hilfe bemerkenswert.
Also bemerkenswert ist halt der also um sowas durchzuziehen musst du halt irgendwie sehr sehr.
Ruhig vorgehen die zeit lassen sehr sehr vorsichtig sein,
und ich meine es ist ja nicht so als könnte das niemand der einzige unterschied wir sehen ja die ganze zeit hacks,
ja in der regel nicht ganz so hohe ziele,
aber bei den hohen zielen sehen wir es ja auch der der unterschied ist nur dass die meisten die da agieren halt staatlich gesponsert oder gedeckt sind,
und hier ist halt jemand der keinerlei schutz genießt keinerlei privilegien nicht.
Entdeckt zu werden oder nicht ausgeliefert zu werden an den feind das ist der das ist der einzige unterschied ist ja nicht so als wüssten wir nicht wie hecken geht was die den mut aufzubringen das durchzuziehen,
und das halt zu paaren mit der mit der absoluten vorsicht,
sich dabei nicht erwischen zu lassen und das ist der eigentliche punkt der das hier besonders macht.
Weil irgendwo groß einsteigen ne das haben schon viele gemacht sind aber dann auch viel dabei erwischt worden.
Ja guck mal wie lange hält paar jahre hält es immerhin schonmal.
Ich hoffe also ich das wäre jetzt nicht die erste leckeren days gönnen würde dass sie erwischt wird so hätte ich andere vorher auf der liste sagen was mal so.
Ja wir haben ja gesagt hacken ist nicht schwer.
Vor allem vor allem wenn's einem die telekom so einfach macht,
ein krasser fall über den heise berichtet.
Und zwar,
ist jemand bei den allgemeinen durchsuchungen des internets auf eine ip-adresse gefunden gestoßen unter der es eine datei freigabe gab und auf diese datei freigabe lagen um die dreißig tausend,
patienten datensätze also dreißigtausend patientinnen mit befunden gesprächs notizen arzt briefen und viele mehr.
Auf einer großen falscher datenbank,
und zwar ein sbb falsch her und,
stellt sich raus das war eine gemeinschaftspraxis in celle,
orthopädische gemeinschaftspraxis die da eben daten von mehreren jahren hatte und da kommt dann eben mal so viele daten zusammen.
Jetzt hat der derjenige der das gefunden hat die arztpraxis irgendwie darüber in kenntnis gesetzt,
und heise online aber auch und die waren jetzt so ein bisschen am rätseln ewig kann wie kann das sein weil die arztpraxis sagte ja ja nee haben wir zugemacht aber die datei freigabe gab es weiterhin.
Und jetzt haben sie das heiße quasi zeitgleich herausgefunden dass es ein back gab,
bei den telekom beruht an mit dem traditionsreichen und wohl kriegen den namen digitalisierung premium.
Super wer denkt sich so ein scheiß eigentlich aus wer denkt sich so was.
Das ist eigentlich auch ein schöner sendung zählen ne,
genau und diese digitalisierung box premium beat halten premium features wenn du sagst du machst eine port freigabe.
Dann hat er gesagt warum eigentlich nur ein.
Wir sind ja hier im geschäftskunden bereich,
warum sollen wir nicht zeigen wenn es einem gut geht so und dann haben sie gesagt hier eingestellt hast und sagst ok ich möchte den port vier vier drei freigeben.
Was der port ist für also es hat der gps verbindung über über l also das was üblicherweise frei depot auf dem ihr spricht,
muss sich das so vorstellen eine ip-adresse die irgendwie da draußen im internet lauert kann.
Und unter verschiedenen ports einen dienst anbieten und dadurch wird im prinzip.
Unterschieden wohin jetzt die anfrage geht ja wenn ihr jetzt an auf einem server ein,
auf einer ip-adresse ein mail server ein webserver und ein harter server ist und eine server dann lauschen die auf unterschiedlichen ports,
auf verbindungen
ja und anhand dieses ports sagt das betriebssystem dann ach ja hier du kommst an port fünfundzwanzig an den hatte der e-mail server,
auf dann gebe ich die nachricht an den e-mails server,
an den webserver weiter,
so und wenn ich jetzt üblicherweise bei euch zu hause steht diese die digitalisierung box premium ja,
es gibt auch standard und smart.
Oh gibt's auch deluxe.
Nee es gibt nur standard smart und premium die sind die sind aber alle premium ja die haben alle diese so wenn ihr das,
die digitalisierung box bringen steht ja die hat erstmal gar kein port auf will man meinen wahrscheinlich hast du fünf posts auf von denen ihr nicht wisst aber so im normalzustand würde sie jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht ganz so viel ports aufhaben wenn ihr nun hinter dieser digitalisierung box premium einen,
server stehen hättet sagen wir ein,
magenta server oder so ja und möchte dass der über das internet erreichbar ist dann würdet ihr die der digitalisierung box premium eine port freigabe einrichten und würde zum beispiel sagen pass auf mach doch mal bitte den port.
Vier vier drei auf ja und wenn du da eine verbindung hast dann,
leitet das weiter an diesen server hier der hinter dieser digitalisierung box premium steht,
und
in üblicherweise würde man sagen wenn du da ein port angibst dann gilt diese freigabe für diesen einen port die digitalisierung box premium legt aber eine schippe drauf und wenn du halt den pott achtzig frei gibst dann geht sie frei
achtzig bis neunundachtzig und wenn du den port vier vier drei,
frei da gibt's die freie port vier vierhundertvierzig bis vierhundertneunundvierzig ja also immer den kompletten zehner blog,
ja und es entweder tai freigabe sind auf port vier vier fünf,
das heißt wenn du dein server.
Lass das recht und.
Oh mein gott
oh mein gott das heißt sie haben die arztpraxis hat alles richtig gemacht ja der dienstleister der arztpraxis der hat 'ne port freigabe für vier vier drei weil die aus irgendwelchen gründen aus der ferne auf diesen vier drei zugreifen wollten
ja und die die digitalisierung und 'ne vier vier fünf für den für das internet praxis netz und die digitalisierung box premium hat,
gesagt was soll's machen wir
und jetzt hat die äh hat heise dass halt eben der deutschen telekom gemeldet und pipapo das ist also das ist wirklich schwerwiegend
das ist eine schwerwiegende schwerwiegender back ja wenn du irgendwie eine port freigabe auf einmal für podcast die dir nicht eingerichtet hast dann wunderst du dich irgendwann spätestens wenn dreißigtausend patientendaten von irgendjemandem mitgenommen wo werden.
Vor allem das ist er.
Und jetzt kommt der knüller telekom wurde gefragt ja jetzt also heißt es mit der story wie online gegangen im november glaube ich,
der sprecher der deutsche telekom hat dann wörtlich gesagt ja wenn sie mich fragen warum es von mai bis heute gedauert hat einen solchen patch anzubieten
da kann ich ihnen darauf keine antwort geben das ist eindeutig ein fehler von uns hier hätten wir schneller gemeinsam mit dem hersteller bin agieren müssen,
so seit mai wusste deutsche telekom davon der patch ist jetzt bereitgestellt worden ja mai,
juni juli august september oktober november halbes jahr.
Millionen ja ewigkeiten ja das ist also vor allem
hier kann man hier weiß man glaube ich auch in etwa wo man draufhauen muss ne das ist einfach mal so klassisches menschliches versagen weil das ist,
ist auch jetzt keine art fehler der so typischerweise beim programmieren mal passiert
sondern so ein quatsch mit ach lass doch mal den ganzen zehner block nehmen.
Ich würde überhaupt nicht einfallen was ein dazu bringen kann außer ein tiefstes.
Tiefstes missverständnis darüber wie das internet funktioniert wie man mit dem umzugehen hat,
und was so die richtigen maßnahmen dafür werden so und sogar dann macht es irgendwie immer noch so richtig gar keinen sinn also zehner blog also.
Ich verstehe auch nicht ich habe gedacht ob du vielleicht mehr erklären kannst wie machst du so ein back wie passiert dir das.
Ja ebene das ist das wo ich wie ja und es hat da gar keine worte dafür also das ist das,
tiefstes tiefstes menschliches versagen,
aber es ist noch nicht mal nur ein programmiert fehler sondern das ist irgendwie 'n planungs- konzept feder der niemals auch nur irgendwo auf einem whiteboard hätte stehen du auf so eine idee,
man nicht.
Genau es ist auf jeden fall ein back mehr so jetzt hast du ich frag mich ernsthaft wieder zustande gekommen ist du kriegst den wert ja.
Also das ding kann auch freigabe wenn du freigabe einrichten bereiche ne das kannst du auch machen kannst sagen hier ich möchte den port bereich machen,
wenn ihr jetzt jemand sagt ich möchte einen bereich haben dann hast du eine funktion die im zweifelsfall,
die port bereiche durchgeht einmal mit einem vor lob oder so und für jeden einzelnen eine was läuft da drauf wahrscheinlich packet filter oder irgendwie firewall deiner deiner wahl ja.
Und setzt halt diese regeln setzt diese podcast weiterleitung rein.
Wie kommst du jetzt dazu dass dir jemand nur einen wert gibt dann sagt achtzig und du sagst jo
achtzig bis neunundachtzig oder vier vier drei oder das ach alles klar vier vierzig bis vier neunundvierzig ich versteh nicht wie du da also normalerweise verstehe ich an back wie der wie der dir passieren kann aber da verstehe ich es nicht,
ich würde mich freuen in den ob du dann doch auf der doch in den lob gegangen ist oder so also ich ich werde ich find spannend wenn ihr hypothesen habt,
in den kommentaren mal erklären könntet wie man wie man darauf kommt.
Eigentlich verstörende daran ist dass es ein zehner bereich ist wenn er.
Acht gewesen wären.
Wenn das hier so irgendwas mit irgendeiner zweier potenz gewesen wäre hätte ich gesagt ja okay da wurde irgendwo was geschichte da wurde ein bild ausgeblendet da wurde irgendwie so also das sind alles so viele da würde ich sogar sagen dass das könnte noch ein fehler sein,
zehn heißt dass diese zahl die da im computer steht entweder während der eingabe noch in so einer maske ja,
oder eben danach wenn's eigentlich bin näher gespeichert ist wird wieder genommen als zehner zahl interpretiert,
um eine zehner stelle verschoben ist alles so maßnahmen die man eigentlich typischerweise im computer extrem explizit tun muss so das passiert einem nicht mal soeben bei.
Also ich war mir sicher dass der back ist irgendwo im pc oder wohin auch immer das web interface von der digitalisierung box premium standard und smart,
geschrieben ist ich glaube nicht dass das irgendwo in einer level sprache wurde deine speicher selber managen muss oder so geschrieben ist ich glaube dass es.
Vor allem dann auch.
Code muss ja dann auch sozusagen von ich mach das für einen auf automatisch in ein ich mache das jetzt ich live jetzt hier wirklich diesen gesamten bereich du also es ist auch noch ein ganz anderer code,
so der muss ja.
Niemand hat den achtzig gegeben der kommt da drauf ja sagt.
Der muss es muss extra dafür geschrieben sein so und dann kann man einfach vorstellen dass da jemand am werke war der einfach,
mich auch nur einen funken eine ahnung hat was phase ist also ich.
Ich hab gehofft dass du vielleicht 'ne ahnung hast wieder wie man so ein back macht.
Ich auch ich auch aber da fällt mir nix zu ein.
Ich gucke mal ob man diese firma ist irgendwo kriegt weil das würde mich wirklich mal interessieren wie die das so ein fehler hab ich auch noch nicht gesehen.
Man muss jetzt auch noch dazu sagen muss auch noch den keks.
Ja aber kaputt.
Sorry bitteschön so schon so spät am morgen diese praxis.
Die die haben alles richtig gemacht.
Nee nee nee die hat keinen webserver dahinten irgendwo in ihrem netz zu betreiben und die hat auch ihre komischen pott,
frei haben auch innerhalb ihrer praxis nicht so auf diese art und weise freizugeben ja weil es war ja dann auch alles komplett ohne zugangs kein passwort und so weiter alles offen das ist auch schon ein großer.
Ja das ist richtig.
Da kommt also das eine und das andere dazu da sieht man mal eben wie sie aus einer kleinen nach lässigkeit immer in dieser annahme naja wir sind ja hinter der feier wahl da kann nichts passieren von wegen,
wenn er dann eins und eins zusammen addierst dann bist du halt schnell bei einhundert und dann,
na ja und dann geht's ab man kann froh sein dass hier die leute die das gefunden haben ist nicht gleich ausgenutzt haben wir ja auch,
wird man ganz was anderes machen können.
Ja das ist auf jeden fall ne also ist 'n ist 'n spannendes ding also klar du hast also ist ein wichtiger punkt man hat keine datei freigabe irgendwo rum zu ballern und man hat in der arztpraxis,
mit einer ordentlichen firewall zu arbeiten die nach listing funktioniert und prinzipiell schon mal die verbindung so oder so nicht durchgelassen hatte.
Ja und auch keine webserver darauf fahren so also das,
offensichtlich ja auch passiert immerhin mit harter p s.
Es ist völlig das war wahrscheinlich weil der dienstleister gesagt hat hör mal wenn ich hier bin ich das machen kann dann freue ich mich nicht mehr die anfahrt zu berechnen.
Ja also die schuld trifft.
Nicht die arztpraxis weil die ganz sicher mit dieser konkreten installation so kaum was zu tun gehabt hat aber entweder ist man da falsch beraten oder falsch ja der service worden.
Wie auch immer spannender also wenn ihr die digitalisierung box premium smart oder das gab's noch standard habt und eine port freigabe,
habt ihr neun kostenlose obendrauf könnte ein problem sein.
Kauft euch vor allem lieber nicht ein roter von der telekom.
Deswegen genau kauft also deswegen man kauft halt ernst zu nehmendes gerät und dann passiert aber das auch nicht zumindest.
Ja wo so auch das unternehmen was es baut auch vorne draufsteht also.
Genau du kaufst dir irgendwas von von der telekom sagst du oder deutsche wertarbeit hier und dann.
Kommen sie auf einmal ja wir haben hier sechs monate mit,
redet so irgendwie morgens aruna abends oder sowas alles scheiße.
Ja ich meine es sind ja ganz alte unternehmen aus dem deutschen digital bereich so.
Das ist eine deutsche firma.
Ja ja bin die am früher wird ihr seht in karten angefangen mit telefonanlage hab ich beide von beiden schon mal produkte besessen,
in ihren besseren zeiten und das dürfte dann irgendwann so gemocht gewesen sein das ist so diese typische zulieferer geschichte in in deutschland.
Stimmt ja sowas sowas passiert auch nur deutschen herstellern.
Ja es ist so ein typisch das ist ja also mich mich wundert es leider nicht ob es schmerzt mich auch einfach wenn ich nur wisse wo.
Wo im gehen strang da mal was ausgelöscht wurde in unserem bereich das muss doch irgendwas mit kosmetik strahlung zu tun haben.
Wir haben da einfach so ein gendefekt so 'ne motivation die uns irgendwie den zugang zum zum digitalen völlig verbaut.
Tja komm wir,
zu einem haben wir noch dramatischere ein thema.
Entschuldigung wir erinnern uns,
zweitausendzwölf geflohen in die,
botschaft von ecuador dann ist er dort rausgeflogen nach sechs sieben jahren dann kam er in in in in großbritannien in haft,
wegen des verstoßes gegen seine koalitionsausschuss sagen er ist ja damals aus der aus dem hausarrest geflohen in die equador iranische botschaft.
Und die usa werfen ihm vor geheimes material von us militär einsetzen im irak und in afghanistan veröffentlicht zu haben die veröffentlichung kennen wir,
und bei einer verurteilung in den usa drohen ihm einhundertfünfundsiebzig jahre haft die usa haben einen auslieferung antrag gestellt.
Und großbritannien hat das auslieferung verfahren zugelassen so er hatte jetzt eine haftstrafe weil er gegen die koalitionsausschuss lagen verstoßen hat da wurde glaube ich zu einem jahr war das glaube ich verurteilt dieses jahr ist jetzt um.
Es war irgendwas zwischen heim und ein jahr nicht ganzen jahr und jetzt ist er aber weiterhin im knast wegen des schwebende auslieferung verfahren und dort.
Der usa nicht mehr schweden.
Nicht mehr schweden genau die haben nämlich,
wieder mal gesagt okay hier kann man nichts mehr mit.
Ich kann nichts mehr passieren kriegen wir nichts mehr geklärt.
Dass diese ganze schweden nummer war ja immer sehr komisch also er hat er hat gesagt ihr könnt mich gerne befragen macht das bitte hier ich bin in dieser equador botschaft ich komme hier nicht raus und schweden hat gesagt nee,
du kommst nach schweden und er hat gesagt nee ich will nicht nach schweden kommen weil ich habe angst dass ihr mich ausliefert und dann haben sie gesagt junge es geht hier um vergewaltigung nicht um auslieferung das haben die,
eigentlich ja sieben jahre lang gespielt dieses spiel da ist auch jetzt irgendwie.
Weiß ich jetzt auch nicht ob der schwedischen krone jetzt gedient wurde dadurch dass da die,
die staatsanwälte hin so und nachgibt ich war dieses verfahren vielleicht auch unter unkonventionellen methoden vielleicht voranzubringen muss man.
Jetzt geht's auf jeden fall um auslieferung.
Jetzt geht's nur noch um auslieferung in die usa jetzt geht's um genau das.
Was ist immer was immer das die sorge war mit julian ja jetzt geht's um das was er im prinzip sieben jahre lang behauptet hat und alle haben gesagt wer du bist doof bleib mal in deiner equador organischen botschaft,
ja jetzt geht's um genau das auslieferung an die usa wegen,
mörder und den darauffolgenden veröffentlichungen,
jetzt war da kürzlich eine gerichts anhörung und also ich meine wieder wie ihr jetzt inzwischen aussieht haben wir gesehen als sie ihn aus der equador iranischen botschaft getragen haben war ja früher immer ein nennt man das ein boot.
Ne
gepflegt gut angezogen sondern rasiert jetzt daraus getragen haben weil sei wirklich irgendwie war noch ein schatten seiner selbst.
Und vor gericht konnte er dem geschehen auch nicht folgen,
und der sonderbar auftragt für folter nils mälzer attestiert ihm typische anzeichen psychologischer folter,
und sagt die briten missachten vollständig die rechte und die integrität von herrn assad solange er hat sich der probleme,
leidet unter depressionen zahnprobleme starke schmerzen in der schulter und kriegt er irgendwie keine,
angemessene versorgung deswegen haben jetzt sechzig ärztinnen und ärzte aus großbritannien deutschland und schweden.
Einen offenen brief geschrieben dass sie sagen er muss jetzt endlich behandelt werden sonst.
Rechnen sie damit dass er in der haft sterben würde oder sterben könnte das ist.
Durchaus krass ja das ist im prinzip das was er immer,
gesagt hat oder was immer die sorge war dass er irgendwann in irgendeinem loch fahr dort und,
unter verletzung seiner menschenrechte irgendwie qualvoll seinem ende entgegen fristen,
und wenn wir uns heute umschauen ist das genau das was mit henning dir auch seit ich glaub einhundert noch was tagen in beuger haft ist,
und ihm jetzt passiert ja dass sie für letztendlich und das aufklären von missständen.
Im militärischen bereich ja.
Ja ihr im prinzip jetzt einfach ihre menschenrechte verloren haben.
Und das ist schon sehr beängstigend das ändert nichts daran,
dass ich wenig bock darauf habe wieso die rolle von wikileaks in den letzten jahren war insbesondere was irgendwie zwanzig fünfzehn sechzehn,
die usa.
Zusammenarbeit mit trump.
Zusammenarbeit mit der trump kampagne erwähnung jungen im maler report und so weiter anbetrifft aber.
Wenn hier mir noch irgendjemand sagen möchte dass der westen sich gegen über china und russland hervor tun solle.
Ja dann würde ich das gerne in diesem fall auch sehen nämlich in dem fall wie man mit seinen schwersten feinden umgeht.
Ja vor allem großbritannien da kann man gerade relativ wenig hoffnung haben dass ich da der politische hinter bauen nennenswert ändert also mit boris johnson,
jetzt nicht unbedingt damit zu rechnen dass jetzt hier sofort mit haft verbesserung zu rechnen.
Ist ne also da müssen wir mal gucken wie die wahl so ausgeht.
Und auch das impeachment dann könnte sich da vielleicht etwas schneller was tun warum das so ist und warum das auch in großbritannien nicht mehr welle macht ist mir ehrlich gesagt unklar aber offenbar ist dieses land zu sehr auch mit sich selbst beschäftigt derzeit.
Also erforscht hat natürlich 'ne ganze menge robin hood.
In den letzten jahren lassen müssen mit einer ganzen reihe.
Kontroverse äußerungen und verhaltensweisen.
Und aktionen aber das schützen,
der menschenrechte die wir hochhalten ist eben genau dann angemessen wenn es um,
ähm darum geht dass sie eben nicht mehr zugestanden werden und es hat auch noch nicht mal was damit zu tun,
die man jetzt zu und schon in der branche selber steht oder nicht das hat etwas damit zu stunden zu tun die man zur eigenen demokratie steht oder nicht aus dem grund,
thema beim kongress übrigens auch.
Wessen thema.
Julian und und seine situation.
Nicht von dir sondern von anders.
Nein nein man sieht doch nur das jetzt gerade der fahrplan und der half navi vom kongress behandelt werden und deswegen fangen wir doch jetzt hier immer die kongress referenzen dazu ein.
So in deutschland bundesverfassungsgerichts urteil,
spannender fall zum recht auf vergessen werden gab es zwei beschlüsse des bundesverfassungsgerichts der erste beschluss ist der sehr viel interessantere und zwar geht es da um den,
paul hermann streisand.
Der in bremen neunzehnhundertzweiundachtzig wegen mordes in zwei fällen und versucht mordes in einem fall zu,
eine lebenslange freiheitsstrafe verurteilt wurde,
die ist hat an bord einer jacht neunzehnhunderteinundachtzig auf hoher see zwei menschen erschossen.
Und der spiegel hat darüber neunzehnhundertzweiundachtzig und neunzehnhundertdreiundachtzig und artikel geschrieben in denen er namentlich,
benannt wird also der paul hermann streisand und seit neunzehnhundertneunundneunzig stellt der spiegel diese sein online archiv auch kostenlos,
im internet bereit ja also wenn du jetzt nach dem paul hermann streisand googlest dann,
findest du auf google den als ersten treffer das,
heft archiv vom spiegel der das neunzehnhundertneunundneunzig online gestellt hat und da in den spiegel von neunzehnhundert zweiundachtzig dreiundachtzig zum zum download anbietet so,
jetzt ist der gute paul seit zweitausendzwei aus dem knast raus und klagt seit zweitausendneun gegen den spiegel.
Und sagt hier ich bin im prinzip mit meiner schuld durch,
und ich möchte jetzt ein rest leben führen,
ohne vorbelastet zu sein durch das was da passiert ist weil ich habe die haftstrafe ab gesessen ich bin jetzt wieder frei und damit bin ich rede sozialisiert,
ich bin nicht mehr öffentlich in erscheinung getreten und wenn nun menschen,
mich kennenlernen und mich googeln wer das meiner sitz meinen sozialen leben meiner persönlichen entfaltung ganz dienlich wenn die nicht immer sofort den spiegel artikel finden.
Und dieses thema haben wir behandeln wir nicht zum ersten mal weil.
Der dass das der spiegel diese sache damals berichtet hat ist ja nach wie vor in ordnung und korrekt.
Und es ist auch nicht das spiegels problem dass er diesen artikel damals geschrieben hat weil presse rechtlich nicht zu beanstanden ist die frage ist nun.
Dass der typ natürlich einen anspruch hat irgendwie seine eigene persönlichkeit irgendwie zu entfalten und er hat jetzt auch seine strafe ab gesessen.
Und jetzt hat das in diesem verfahren hat jetzt das bundesverfassungsgericht geurteilt dass der spiegel,
zumutbar vorkehrungen gegen die auffindbarkeit der artikel in betracht ziehen müsste.
Es werden also jetzt hier meinungs- und pressefreiheit gegen das allgemeine persönlichkeitsrechte aufzuregen und der faktor warum das jetzt auf einmal,
aufzuwiegeln ist ist weil das berechtigte interesse an einer identifizieren den berichterstattung mit zunehmendem zunehmendem zeitlichen abstand,
zur tat abnehme ja sagten so ja zweiundachtzig dreiundachtzig konntet ihr den namen schreiben.
Es war ein krasser fall ne mord in der karibik und so deswegen spielt auch verkaufen und so und jetzt aber.
Ne fast vierzig jahre später tut der name nichts mehr zur sache das heißt das bundesverfassungsgericht malt stellt sich quasi so eine kurve vor,
mit der der das berechtigte interesse an einer identifizieren den berichterstattung zunehmen abnehme und gleichzeitig das persönlichkeitsrechte der person wieder zunimmt,
und wenn sie urteilen sieb in diesem fall hat der klagen ende.
Der paul hermann streisand ein recht,
dass diese informationen auch mal langsam wieder vergessen werden jetzt ist es aber so das bundesverfassungsgericht kann ja immer nur urteile.
Einsacken,
die andere gerichte gesprochen haben oder sagen das ist falsch es kann es schreibt aber nicht vor,
wie es jetzt neu zu gestalten ist es kann immer nur sagen so geht das nicht und sagen jetzt welche.
Ja sie können schon vorgaben machen wie das.
Genau genau wie das zu gestalten ist aber welche maßnahmen spezifisch das müssen eben andere fachgerechte klären oder eventuell auch andere gesetze.
Das heißt das bundesverfassungsgericht hat jetzt nicht gesagt wieder wie das passieren muss denn das interessante ist ja,
dass der typ auf google gefunden wird liegt ja eigentlich an google und nicht am spiegel und,
ich bin jetzt ohnehin ein bisschen verwundert weil wir doch schon dieses recht auf vergessen werden ohnehin haben und
quasi geltend machen können gegenüber google dass wir bestimmte dinge nicht in unseren suchergebnissen haben wollen und der der rechtliche anspruch den wir da haben ist das,
kugel de facto zu einem,
in dem fall zu einer person ein profil anlegt,
und sagt auf diese suchanfragen geben wir folgendes raus mit anderen worten das fällt uns zu der person ein ähnlich wie twitter und facebook das dann auch kura tieren.
Und ich ginge eigentlich davon aus dass er in der lage sein müsste,
bei google zu sagen ich möchte das nicht dass das angezeigt wird denn spiegel online kann,
das nicht wirklich gewährleisten dass er nicht in irgendeiner suchmaschine wiedergefunden wird die könnten jetzt in die robots texte schreiben,
das soll nicht infiziert werden hier dann können die aber trotzdem,
also man muss sich ja keiner dran halten da könnt ihr eine suchmaschine sagen wir ignorieren die roberts text das ist ja nur ein freundlicher freundliches angebot ja insofern könnte.
Die spiegel online gmbh oder die spiegel gmbh zwar versuchen das zu tun,
sie könnte es aber nicht garantieren und insofern weil sie es nicht garantieren könnte wer sie ja dann auch schwer dazu zu verklagen oder dafür haftbar zu machen und jetzt ist halt die frage was ist denn jetzt zumutbar.
Also ein sehr interessantes eine sehr interessante gemengelage ich habe gerade gesagt es sind zwei fälle über die entschieden wurde denn der zweite fall.
Warte mal vielleicht zu dem fall noch ich find's ganz interessant dass man hier nicht einen anderen weg auch noch erwogen hat der eigentlich für alle beteiligten sehr viel einfacher umzusetzen wäre das ist nämlich einfach einen neuen namen zu legt.
Äh ja aber das war ein maximal schwerer ein einschnitt in seinen persönlichkeitsrechte wenn du sagst ja du musst jetzt einen neuen namen nehmen weil spiegel irgendeine seite online hat das geht ja auch nicht.
Na wieso es geht um ein recht auf vergessen werden das ist damit dann auf jeden fall äh geleistet.
Ich meine wenn sein ganzes leben bis dahin im wesentlichen daraus bestand was möchte er das dass man es auch findet irgendwie die die berichte von seinen klassen partys vorher.
Jetzt halt die berichte von seinem klagen zu gegen.
Naja ebenso ich meine der dame ist doch jetzt komplett wollt
und da ist ja niemanden mit getan nein das wird nicht alle fälle in denen dieser klageweg beschritten wird abdecken
nur muss man sich meiner meinung nach auch mal darüber gedanken machen wie halt dieser wunsch sozusagen am besten erfüllt wird und wenn der eigene name einfach auf diese art und weise komplett
in meiner hast halt leute umgebracht und was lebenslänglich im im knast sorry weitere beiträge zum kulturellen geschehen sind in den namen nicht geleistet worden,
und abgesehen davon was mit den anderen leuten die polt hermann heißen also.
Da über die über die darf dann auch nichts mehr gefunden werden so was ist wenn der nächste pasta irgendwie polt hermann heißt das macht ein google muss dann irgendwie alle paul hermanns auch noch unterscheiden also,
das sind ja auch alles so so begriffe die sind irgendwie in gewisser hinsicht beliebig.
Deswegen würde ich noch also der zweite fall da geht es um eine person,
die in einem beitrag des magazins panorama der der titel des beitrags war kündigung die fiesen tricks der arbeitgeber hat sie ein interview geben und in dem beitrag,
wird sie können ihre die von ihr vorgenommene kündigung eines damaligen mitarbeiters behandelt.
In einem unternehmen dass sie als geschäftsführerin leitete und sie sagt jetzt,
dieser dieser bericht wenn man das jetzt wenn man jetzt ihren namen googelt dann findet man nämlich auf,
findet man auf der ndr seite diesen bericht indem sie aufgetreten ist weil der ndr denn in der mediathek mit ihrem namen verschlag wartet hat.
Und dann sagt sie ja hier hallo ich möchte ähm recht auf vergessen werden in anspruch nehmen und ich hätte gerne,
dass der ndr meinen namen aus der verschlag wartung dieses mediathek beitrages rausnimmt.
Wohlgemerkt von zweitausendzehn neun jahre her da sagt das bundesverfassungsgericht nö wir sehen,
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt keinen anspruch auf aus listung,
weil so nach neun jahren geht noch.
Dass es so sagte bundesverfassungsgericht was ich jetzt auch sehr spannend finde was heißt offenbar zehn jahre lang kann irgendetwas dir zum verhängnis werden vierzig jahre später aber nicht.
Wo fängt man da an ich meine vierzig jahren keinen.
Nimmt sie wahrscheinlich eine an den wirtschaftlichen leben wo ihr sozusagen das jetzt in die quere kommen kann nicht mehr teil.
Vermutlich ähm.
Zeigt eigentlich nur wie knifflig und schwierig diese ganze vergessen werden geschichte ist.
Und ich bin trotzdem.
Also ich find's halt voll ich meine den spiegel dazu zu zwingen das offline zu nehmen,
bin ich absolut inakzeptabel so das kann ich das kann nicht die lösung sein die.
Suchmaschinen in irgendeiner form.
Zu einer korrektur der summe suchergebnisse zu zwingen,
kann aber auch ein riesiges problem sein weil was meinst du wen es noch alles gibt,
der oder die sachen aus dem internet gerne raus hätten,
und sich in ihrer in der ausübung ihrer freien persönlichkeit irgendwie eingeschränkt sehen wenn jetzt irgendwie rainer wendt zum beispiel ne dieser korrupte der gar kein polizist ist ne wenn man den,
der hat zum beispiel auch eine ganze menge im internet die er wahrscheinlich da gerne raus hätte.
Solider und so.
Lieder alles ist ja gar kein echter polizist so und den oder irgendwelche hier so,
manager und steuer betrüger und sowas ne die haben alle was werden die an der freien ausübung ihrer persönlichkeit gehindert wenn die da im internet so schlechte berichterstattung.
Ja die aktuelle regierung besetzung des weißen hauses.
Also da gibt's,
zeug und das wird natürlich dann ein absoluter spieß guten lauf also,
ich kann so ein bisschen verstehen,
was mit diesem recht geschaffen werden sollte ich glaube aber das wird einfach scheitern also es wird auf der einen seite kein effizientes werkzeug sein können und auf der anderen seite sehr viel mehr ärger bringen.
Als man ohnehin schon hatte und lässt einfach so ein bisschen,
die realitäten des digital wesens außer acht das ist so ein ja das kann ja nicht sein dass,
aber manchmal kann das halt sein dass es alles nicht geht.
Spannende frage auf jeden fall.
Aber ich habe einen tipp man könnte ja einfach der zugriff auf dieser artikel.
Langsam.
So verlangsamen das das selbst wenn man den link gefunden hat dass man einfach gar nicht runtergeladen bekommt das das wäre doch vielleicht ein trick.
Ja hier.
Ich glaube deutschland hatte auch ist da führend in diesem technologie bereich.
Oh man ey.
Ja man hat nämlich nach gemessen und.
Stellt sich raus internet ist langsam.
Internet ist langsam in deutschland ja.
Sie merken alles.
Boom.
Die merken alles ja.
Es gibt dann auch jetzt irgendwie die dieses beispiel wo leuten der zugang abgeschaltet wird in ländlichen gebieten das war das beste was sie hatten ja und,
die telekom schaltet jetzt diese erste endkunden auf ipc um und das telekommunikation gesetz verlangt dann einen funktionalen internetanschluss,
so und dann wurde die bundesnetzagentur gefragt ja was ist denn funktional,
was ist denn nach eurer maßgabe funktional und dann haben sie gesagt,
sechsundfünfzig kilometer ist funktional woraufhin dann.
Matthias schindler sein rechner.
Auf der seite internetzugang auf sechsundfünfzig kilo bit gedrosselt hat und die website der bundesnetzagentur aufgerufen hat zehn minuten gedauert,
haben sie noch die bundestags homepage dauert fast zwanzig minuten.
Funktionaler internetzugang ja was willst du machen tim das ist hier vorbei das wir sehen dass,
internet ist stabil aber eben langsam.
Sechsundfünfzig kilometern man muss mal vielleicht mal kurz erklären wie es zu dieser zahl überhaupt kommt also damals,
m als wir als wäre noch nichts tim hatten ja also meine einer hat so seine ersten daten kommunikation also es ist erstmal in einem daten netz angeschlossen war hatte ich so ein mode mit.
Tausendzweihundert pro sekunde so hin und her das war schon irre und es,
hat sich dann schnell verdoppelt und dann hat man zweitausendvierhundert anfang der neunziger und dann soll man immer bei neuntausend sechshundert und lalala da ging es immer so weiter bis man an so das erste technische limit,
erreicht hat von analogen telefonleitung und das lag so bei dreiunddreißig tausend sechshundert pro sekunde.
Mit prosecco zeichen pro sekunden ist kannst du nochmal durch durch zehn teilen also kriegst du drei tau dreitausenddreihundert buchstaben pro sekunde oder deine leitung gespürt buchstaben.
So schnell kannst du doch gar nicht schreiben tim das ist sowohl für das reicht ja wohl aus.
Hast du eine ahnung seit jahrelang geübt wurde immer schneller immer schneller da kommt man langsam rein.
Parallel dazu wurde dann das,
aufgebaut was an sich ein großer wurf war dem eine technologie der aber leider der rest der welt nicht so richtig folgen wollte vor allem nicht die usa deswegen ist es auch so ein bisschen gescheitert in london.
Und das hatte ja bei message beschleunigung ne vierundsechzig kilo pro kanal man kriegt gleich zwei,
hundertachtundzwanzig kilowatt kriegt man aus einem normalen es null anschluss irgendwie raus,
und durch die zunehmende digitalisierung und wirklich den neunziger jahren hatten wir wirklich das beste telefoniert sehr welt,
ist es dann auch möglich geworden aus diesem modell auf einmal mehr rausholen weil wenn die gegenseite sozusagen rein digital es musste man da eben nicht mehr analog rum wurschteln für die simulation und deswegen waren auf einmal mit bestimmten modus diese sechsundfünfzig kilo bitte,
möglich es war sozusagen die versorgung für analoge anschluss teilnehmer mit speziellen moslems die das machten die beim provider anrufen die aber eigentlich über ihr ist die einleitung verfügt das war sozusagen die sechsundfünfzig kilometer kommen die her.
Ach echt.
Ja man man hätte halt auch zu hause.
Vom sechsundfünfzig k zum sechsundfünfzig kam über analog sechsundfünfzig sprechen können.
Nee das war dann so diese dreiunddreißig sex aber dann irgendwie schloss und.
Ach echt ja das wusste ich zum beispiel auch nicht ich dachte das wäre noch normale vollständig analoge module die moderation gewesen.
Da kommt das her und die leute die dann halt einen anschluss dann auch hatten irgendwann,
die konnten dann halt so mal hundert achtundzwanzig kilo mitmachen wenn sie den provider gefunden haben der das auch angeboten hat die gab's ja dann auch irgendwann so genau diese leute die jetzt immer noch kein schnelles internet haben,
sondern quasi immer noch so mit mit mit dem mit der verheißung der neunziger jahre surfen,
im jahr zwanzig neunzehn ja wir sind jetzt kurz vor
den zwanziger jahren golden anbrechen,
ich höre schon den digitalen charles in meinen ohren klingeln und die sind also immer noch so mit letzten jahrhundert technologie ausgestattet,
und den wird jetzt das erste mal hier ist der wird ja abgeschaltet und also ja ihr könnt ja neuen anschluss haben aber gibt 's leider nicht,
und das heißt eh schon so total gefickt und müssen jetzt auch noch,
und dann kommen so leute daher und sagen hier unser unser monheim hack aus den neunzigern ja wo wir den leuten noch nicht mal in der lage waren diese diese diese diese dünn vierundsechzig kilo bei zu geben.
Das ist jetzt einfach mal der standard also dafür muss man sich einfach nur schämen für so einen kommentar.
Tja funktional die haben wir nicht gesagt ist der standard das ist das minimum was sie voraussetzen immerhin das ist ja schon mal ganz nett also dass sie wenigstens sagen dass dass das auch wirklich das absolute minimum ist es hätte immer noch schlimmer kommen könnte.
Du hast selber gesagt wenn was hättest du gemacht wenn du jetzt gesagt hätten dreiunddreißig sechs reicht funktioniert funktioniert doch.
Komm da wird 's raus oder nicht.
Ich bin in den neunziger jahren rumgelaufen und hab immer gesagt ich fordere ein mensch menschenrecht auf mindestens zwei megabit anschluss weil ich das damals für auch absolut realistisch gehalten habe weil so ein hier ist der in primär multiplikator anschluss der hatte ja sozusagen auch zwei megabit,
in beide richtungen und da sind wir heute noch nicht.
Ja aber deswegen,
andi scheuer ja ist wieder in die welt hinaus gefahren und war in brandenburg und wird jetzt bereitstellen eins komma eins milliarden für mobilfunk masten,
bis also bis zwanzig vierundzwanzig wieder eins komma eins milliarden euro,
über das sondervermögen digitale infrastruktur,
im kampf gegen funklöcher ausgeben.
Ganz ehrlich was soll ich dazu sagen ich finde das gut besser als nicht.
Nee klar aber ich meine das erzählen sie uns jetzt auch schon seit jahren also ich meine wie wie viele daten gab's jetzt schon wann dann endlich alles gut ist also das ist das das das geht aus.
Du wenn die wenn die das machen ja wenn sie das machen hier mit den,
bis zwanzig vierundzwanzig mit eins komma eins milliarden euro ein paar funklöcher stopfen ne dann können die vielleicht ernsthaft dieses ziel erreichen dass wir bis zwanzig fünfzig in allen bussen wlan haben.
Du weißt wenn weder final abgeschaltet wird weil eigentlich alle nur noch sechs gebe nutzen.
Funktional.
Komm jetzt kommen wir zu guten nachricht wir haben eine gute nachricht das muss man einfach sagen es ist eine gute nacht.
Oh wirklich.
Ja
Aux
Der trinker mit der machete,
wer erinnert sich noch an den trinker mit der machete diesen afd spinner der da mit einem halben glas bier und der machete abends zu hause saß und irgendwie ich glaube das zentrum für politische schönheit und die antifa bedroht hat.
Wie hieß es ihre ihre standarten noch die totenkopf die afd totenkopf stand.
Afd totenkopf standorte hier.
Erzfeind der erzfeind der npd einhorn standard.
Ja stefan brandner leider,
zu einem also ein stand mal war das ja für den deutschen bundestag dass dieser typ dann ernsthaft,
der vorsitzende des rechtsausschuss des war er ungefähr genauso also wahrscheinlich dachte er rechtsausschuss geil da bin ich richtig schön rechts.
Ist ein bisschen flach.
Ist ein bisschen flacher oder fällt mir gerade eigentlich was ich glaube süddeutschland da auch irgendwie so ein foto von von gauland und,
was immer wieder über die andere person auf dem foto war vielleicht was,
die weide und dann ein bild unterschrift so,
gauland in klammern rechts oder wie alles weitere klammern auch rechts.
Auch recht.
Der auf jeden fall der hat sich ja dann irgendwie also mit dem besoffen twittern geht bei ihm irgendwie läuft und hat sich dann.
Aufgeregt über ein ich glaube ein antifaschistische statement von udo lindenberg,
weil und udo lindenberg wurde ausgezeichnet mit irgendeinem preis und dann sagte er das ist jetzt der judas lohn für das für sein verrat am deutschen volk ja,
so das hat sich dann irgendwann der rechtsausschuss auch gesagt ey alter wir können hier nicht so ein so ein machete nazi irgendwie da vorne sitzen lassen dass das geht so nicht ne dann haben sie,
eben sich in der ich würde sagen in der bemühung die würde des des hauses irgendwie zu retten,
gesagt okay komm dann müssen wir denn jetzt abwählen ja,
und ich denke der typ dem ist auch wirklich nicht mehr zu helfen also irgendwie sein dieses machete ding hat ihn ja sowieso schon disqualifiziert bis oben hin,
was war das das war ja gar keine machete das war ja irgendwie so eine.
Unser werkzeug.
Nee so eine osmanische war auch noch irgendwie so ein osmanischen messer wir wurden damit wir wunder noch korrigiert dass das noch nicht mal eine machete war sondern.
Überhaupt messer vielleicht weil es einfach.
Nein nein das war so ein so ein allerdings selbe das war auf jeden fall kein arabisches messer das war.
Arabischer bierdeckel öffnen.
Genau ist auf jeden fall keine keine keine kein arabischer degen sondern irgendwie so ein,
auf jeden fall kein rein deutscher keine rein deutsche kleiner und,
ja jetzt hab ich jetzt immer den spinner endlich los was schön ist weil ich ja das ein oder andere mal auch als sachverständiger im rechtsausschuss war und ich ernsthaft mir überlegt hätte,
wenn ich da nochmal eingeladen worden wäre in der zeit in der er damit der machete den laden in fach gehalten hat.
Ob ich wie ich da noch den respekt hätte waren sollen vor so einem,
nach hinten trinker so spannend ist aber also das ist stefan,
severin weiland nicht der focus money
kommentiert das als eine würdige abwahl und das ist auch richtig dass dieser
typ abgewählt wurde spannend ist und wirklich man sieht dann auch wirklich mit was für leute man ist da zu tun hat und wow warum das gut war den abzuwählen das hören wir am jetzigen einspieler denn wir machen ja selten ein spieler in logbuch netz politik
aber diese,
pressekonferenz im anschluss an seine abwahl als vorsitzender dieses ausschusses die ist schon sehr bemerkenswert.
Aux
Wir hören gauland.
Sportsfreunde.
Alter was für asoziale.
Ja ja es kann ja auch keiner keiner mehr die meinung sagen.
Ja
Nur das irgendwie diese pegida hansel ist jetzt wie lange irgendwie jede woche ihren scheiß in die welt rausschreien.
Also das ist wirklich.
Naja opfer inszenierung deluxe.
Was der seit der unglückliche riet feed zu halle ne für den er sich entschuldigt hat der lautete
kapiere ich sowieso nicht
die opfer des amokläufer von halle waren jana eine deutsche die gerne volksmusik hörte kevin s ein bio deutscher warum lungern politiker mit kerzen in moscheen und synagogen rum.
Unglücklicher red.
Von wir waren in der.
Von einem twitteraccount hartes geld.
Unglücklicher red das ist.
Sehr unglücklich.
Ja unglücklich das ist einfach als soziale also ist wirklich erstaunlicher oder diese.
Also auch sie wie wir hören ja da die gute alice seide wie sie dann da irgendwie wirklich auch diese journalisten beide ja die auf jeden fall wie sie.
Alles ziemlich.
Souverän also wie oh das ist ja also also kindisch und katastrophale deutschland merkel staat so.
Unvorstellbar unvorstellbar keine.
Also man fragt sich ernsthaft wieviel denen im leben versagt worden sein muss dass sie auf so strange trichter kommen das ist wirklich beängstigend.
Da ist auch methode einfach ne also es ist einfach so man ist ihn jetzt sich halt als opfer und,
wenn sie auf uns einschlagen dann meint er ja gleich alle damit und so deswegen müsst ihr uns ja auch verteidigen mal so dieser p also eine bestimmte bevölkerungsgruppen um den,
einzureden das wären jetzt so die verteidiger ihrer freiheit dabei sind das und wie die ersten dir die freiheit genommen werden wenn sie denn mal wirklich so könnten wie sie wollten.
Und,
das ist natürlich das klassische populisten nazi problem so das ist nicht neu damit müssen wir jetzt irgendwie klarkommen.
Das das fügt sich in diese,
meinungsfreiheit debatten der letzten äh der letzten wochen irgendwie sehr schön eine wo ja auch diese.
Ernsthaft leute der ansicht wenn man es gäbe in deutschland keine meinungsfreiheit mehr interesse
natürlich du kannst denn hier alles sagen was du willst solange du irgendwie auch die konsequenzen dafür trägst so du kannst auch alles was er gesagt hat kann normaler mensch auch jederzeit sagen,
ja aber niemand der dem deutschen rechtsausschuss vorsitz,
so wenn er schon keine kompetenz in dem in dem fachbereich hat sondern da nur sitzt weil eben irgendein ausschuss auch an die schwach marken gehen muss ja also der dass sie ich meine könntest auch,
also ich versteh überhaupt nichts die können ja auch nicht im bundestag an die wand pissen und sagen wie geht's dir keine persönlichen freiheitsrechte mehr so also können sie machen,
würden sie wahrscheinlich auch nicht für bestraft werden aber müssen sie halt die konsequenzen von tragen und dieses ich bin mir auch gar nicht so sicher ob man sich auf diese stoß debatte überhaupt noch einlassen soll mit diesen idioten,
also mit dem meinungsfreiheit und so das drehen sie doch wirklich wie du schon sagst einfach leuten ein,
noch so 'n opfer ach noch so ein opfer auch eine gute nachricht eigentlich oder ist das noch nee ist keine gute nachricht denn der ist noch nicht,
der ist noch nicht rechtsausschuss vorsitzender des immer noch was ist eigentlich der wird immer noch bezahlt als polizist ne.
Es gibt da wo.
Ist das ja gar kein polizist.
Fang ansprüche in nrw irgendwie mit dem sich jetzt in der wg irgendwie rumschlagen muss die rede ist natürlich von rainer wendt.
Kein polizist.
Der vorsitzende der ist das eigentlich jetzt noch polizeigewerkschaft oder haben sie jetzt irgendwie rausgeworfen.
Ja natürlich der ist ja klar.
Genau die polizeigewerkschaft immer so den eindruck macht als würde sie für alle polizisten sprechen dabei ist ja auch nur eine polizeigewerkschaft und nicht die polizeigewerkschaft.
Die depot das ist sogar noch die kleinere,
also es gibt oder die mir bekannten interessenvertretung der polizei bund deutscher kriminalbeamter depot und fdp sind glaube ich in der reihenfolge größer werden.
Das sind so die drei interessenvertretung die ich da die mir so bekannt sind ja also eine ein.
Bundespolizei gewerkschaft deutsche polizeigewerkschaft euro kopf gibt's auch gewerkschaft der polizei gewerkschaft der volkspolizei aus das war früher ja.
Ja der wollte oder sollte jetzt irgendwie im in sachsen-anhalt staatssekretär im innenministerium werden aufgrund welcher qualifikation eigentlich.
Das ist eine sehr gute frage das weiß wahrscheinlich nur der innenminister herrscht stahlknecht tja.
Der könnte man seinen namen ändern für das ist halt in wasser.
Ja
Wenn du da ankommt und sagt hallo ich heiße wie heißt der nochmal hermann steinbach oder,
ich heiße herman streisand da sein die aus sondern als annahme aber wenn du sagst ich heiße stahlknecht,
der könnte es ja schon mal einen anderen namen so da könnt ihr mit dem guck mal der soll einfach der kann ja mit dem hermann tauschen.
Super.
Wir sind beide happy.
Ja wir möchten sie denn jetzt heißen ja steigt nicht okay machen witze übernahm ist jetzt auch wirklich ein bisschen dünn.
Ja ja ja ist denn mach mal lieber witze über inhalte.
Also was eigentlich passiert also der innenminister herr stahl knecht in sachsen anhalt von der cdu hielte es für eine tolle idee doch rainer wind als,
staatssekretär in sein innenministerium zu holen weil er sich ja so unglaublich kompetent über alle fragen der inneren sicherheit geäußert hat in den letzten jahren bundespolitik berichtete mehrfach netz politik berichtete am laufenden meter und,
jan böhmermann hat auch alles wesentliche was man so rainer wendt wissen muss,
schön musikalisch zusammen gefegt,
problem war nur dieser plan war wohl irgendwie überhaupt nicht abgestimmt und zwar sowohl nicht so richtig in seiner eigenen partei und was noch viel schlimmer ist schon gar nicht auf koalitions ebene,
und da da ja gerade eine ganz große koalition unterwegs ist,
haben wir natürlich dann auch so ein bisschen was mitzureden und kaum dass diese nachricht dann herauskam also er hat dann ihm also im dem dem rainer wind,
die zusage mündliche natur gemacht so hier du bist jetzt bei uns staatssekretär.
Und dann hat er seinen koalitionspartner.
Und dann ist es irgendwie geliebt ich weiß nicht ob es selber erzählt hat habe ich es nicht so im einzelnen verfolgt auf jeweils es dann irgendwie,
die runde machte haben sich die spd und grüne sofort dagegen stellung gesagt habt ihr sie noch alle,
wenn ihr den vogel hier reinhold dann gibt's auch hier richtig ärger daraufhin explodierte es wohl auch innerhalb der cdu ein wenig im mangels absprache und schon
selbst wenn er wenn er die idee intern geäußert hat gab es zumindest wohl keinen konsens darüber dass man ihn es auch werden lassen sollte von daher war dann eben seine mögliche zusage nochmal ein extra problem,
mittlerweile ist die ganze idee vom tisch und rainer wendt wird nicht staatssekretär im innenministerium.
Und nicht nur wegen des,
politischen druck sondern auch weil er seit zweitausendsiebzehn ein disziplinarverfahren in nordrhein-westfalen an der backe hat weil er da aus außer aufsichtsrat gremien zahlungen erhalten hat die er nicht angegeben hat,
so und da wird er wird er halt pensionen kürzungen im zweifelsfall bekommen das ist also ein,
neben verdienste nicht angemeldet ne eignet sich also auf jeden fall für eine politische karriere der mann so und wie ist deine.
Die man von polizisten sich.
Das ist die integrität die wir uns von polizisten wünschen das ist die integrität die wir uns in im innenministerium wünschen von vorne bis hinten krumme korrupter typ,
ja was sagt so jemand wenn er wenn er dann endlich mal seine quittung bekommt von den verbleibenden anständigen.
Na die anderen sind schuld.
Das kommando dazu kam aus dem kanzleramt.
Ich hätte die aufgabe gerne übernommen sie ist von der landesregierung an mich herangetragen wurden in den vergangenen tagen sind lügen und falsch darstellung über mich verbreitet worden die cdu ist von linken grünen und sozialdemokraten beraten eingeknickt und hat
kapituliert danke rainer wendt,
was für eine flachpfeifen ja jetzt bläst er auch noch ins horn von diesen von diesen rechten also ich meine hat ja schon immer gemacht ne das ist der typ der auf google streetfood streife fahren wollte aber.
Das ist der typ der afd regierung unter garantie schon zur staatssekretär ernannt werden wird aber sowas schnell von.
Mann ey das ist wirklich es ist wirklich,
ich finde es zunehmend belastend und erbärmlich den.
Was diese leute für ein unsinn von sich geben ja also so wie wofür haben wir denn.
Wir hatten eigentlich also wir versuchen zumindest in den politischen system daraufhin zu arbeiten das kompetente menschen,
mit kompetenz dieses land regieren mit mit bildung und wissen und mit verantwortungsbewusstsein und solche äußerungen sind einfach verantwortungslos ja weil es da draußen leider immer noch genug deppen gibt die so ein mist dann auch glauben.
Als wenn die als weiß als wenn rainer wendt als wenn die kanzlerin zeit hätte sich mit rainer wendt auseinanderzusetzen und ein kommando nach sachsen-anhalt zu geben.
Ob sie das selber getan hat ok also das kann ja sogar sein.
Dass sie gesagt hat seid ihr bescheuert.
Gehabt da habt ihr sie noch alle also natürlich,
die werden die sofort zurück gepfiffen haben ich meine ihre eigene groko ist ja schon im wanken und dann irgendwie noch so eine nummer starten ich meine in der erfahrene beruf politikerin die angela merkel richtig probleme noch hier zehnmal gegen den wind,
und der typ noch nicht mal wenn der wenn der sturm über ihn hereingebrochen ist also ist schon geil ne und hier zum thema afd hier der jan wenzel schmidt,
ist und afd vogel aus sachsen-anhalt meinte so ja aber der wind der sei doch ein hoffnungsschimmer,
für das von steigt nicht geführte innenministerium leute echt.
Hoffnungsschimmer.
Doof und.
So peter stolz auch bei uns.
Mehrmals behandelt weil er in der türkei verhaftet wurde.
Weil er dort menschenrechts trainings gemacht hat und zwar zusammen mit mc international,
jetzt gab es die verlösung der anklageschrift des plädoyers der staatsanwaltschaft in diesem gerichtsverfahren interessanterweise.
Sagt der staatsanwalt in istanbul ja also gegen den stollen haben wir nix alles in ordnung.
Den wollen wir frei sprechen aber fünf weitere an also den tatjana killer den ehren vorsitzenden von international in der türkei,
gegen den haben wir was und äh fünf weitere die sollen in mehreren punkten,
verurteilt werden nämlich sie sind terroristen oder unterstützer einer terrororganisation wir wissen also international die bombe ja die ganze zeit bomben die einen nach dem anderen weg ne das ist ja,
kennen wir ja diese terrororganisation international ne.
Insofern für peter stolz nichts keine gute nachricht also alles also er,
nimmt das halt zur kenntnis als eine gesamt ungerechtigkeit,
und kann entsprechend wenig freude daran finden,
dass man ihnen nun frei sprechen will ich glaube der hat ja auch lange genug gelitten da wird jetzt irgendwie ich mein das von ihn frei spricht und auch alle anderen frei spät wäre,
eine selbstverständlichkeit und jetzt bin ich mal gespannt ob deutschland da noch weiter druck machen wird für die leute von international oder ob deutschland sich davon dadurch jetzt quasi ja ich sag mal weg kaufen lässt ne.
Aber wir gehen jetzt mal so ein bisschen in die kurz meldungen rein weil die sendung ist ja schon relativ lang.
Social media habe ich den nächsten abschnitt genannt tiktok du kennst tim ja ich kenne das auch.
Also ich weiß es gibt.
Passau kanal.
Ne ich ich wüsste nicht was ich tick trocken soll da gibt's ja hauptsächlich irgendwelche.
Sei mal inhalt inhalts schwachen unterhaltung es videos und das hat mich kam mir bisher noch keine idee aber.
Felix rosa asis hatte eine ja die hat nämlich ein schönes video gemacht,
wo sie das beginnt mit hier jetzt zeige ich zeige ich euch einen einfachen trick wie man sich seine wimpern verlängert,
und dann hat er schon so eine so eine wimperverlängerung und sagt also ganz kurz und ihr redet dann,
also ich würde sagen zwanzig sekunden hat zehn sekunden über menschenrechtsverletzungen in china zeigt am ende wir mit dieser zange über die augen gehen muss dass die wimpern anders aussehen,
und.
Dieses video ist halt viral gegangen weil es also es ist halt sehr gut gemacht ne fängt halt eigentlich so ein beauty video,
hat eine knallharte politische botschaft und ist dann wieder weg na ja und dieser account war dann halt auch.
Und netzwerk org hatte eine recherche.
Veröffentlicht dass das natürlich kein zufall ist sondern dass es eine sehr klare direkte zensur auf tiktok gibt was politische inhalte angeht ja ist ein chinesisches,
soziales netzwerk ich meine wenn wir uns die amerikanischen anschauen was erwarten wir dann.
Von einem chinesischen insofern bleibt da mal von weg.
Das ist aber ganz unterhaltsam auf eine bestimmte art und weise.
Ja das mag sehr das mag sehr wohl sein aber die revolution werden wir damit nicht machen mit unterhaltsamen videos ne dritter.
Aber mit unterhaltsam podcast.
Mit unterhaltsam podcast machen wir die revolution ja.
Twitter hat irgendwie großes thema mit accounts zu löschen wir haben gesagt ok pass auf,
wir schreiben jetzt meine e-mails an accounts die ich dort ein halbes jahr oder was nicht mehr benutzt wurden und,
dann gelten die als inaktiv und jetzt werden wollen wir mal eine ganze reihe in aktiver benutzernamen loswerden.
Und das fand ich eigentlich jetzt nicht so eine blöde idee aber stößt natürlich auch an eine reihe probleme.
Denn es gibt ja auch menschen die gestorben sind in der zwischenzeit und deren accounts deshalb vielleicht inaktiv sind und dann geht's ja auch vielleicht um deren andenken oder was ja das jetzt irgendwie den twitteraccount nicht nicht,
gelöscht und durch jemand anderen übernommen wird also auch da werden wir die debatte jetzt gar nicht unbedingt aufmachen aber das ist natürlich auch ein ein,
problemfelder ja wir alle haben wahrscheinlich irgendwann account auf dem wir eigentlich ein auge haben der seit acht jahren,
keine tweets von sich gegeben hat wo man sagt boah wenn ich den hätte könnte ich damit was total schönes machen,
andererseits vielleicht ist da wie das wie das individual schicksale dahinter ist eben dann auch eine andere frage.
Ja also mich wundert ein wenig dass sie das nicht auf der kette hatten also ich meine wie schlecht kennt ihr eigentlich ihre.
Das ist das ist schon irgendwie,
bis ins training grundsätzlich begrüße ich das ja dass das das so so accounts die jetzt ganz offensichtlich auch weil es gibt ja auch welche die so offensichtlich nicht benutzen.
Zwei drei mal irgendwas weg gefeuert wurde und dann war das passwort vergessen und damit ist das ding dann irgendwie durch oder wo die e-mail adresse dann auch,
was weiß ich ein jahr lang nicht mehr erreichbar ist da kann man dann wirklich davon ausgehen,
ja okay das mit der e-mail-adresse ist jetzt nicht so das gute beispiel weil er spielt natürlich dann voll wieder in diese person ist gestorben nummer rein aber zumindest die kombination aus dem ganzen ich wurde auch schon auf zwei von mir wenig genutzte accounts,
hingewiesen den einen habe ich auch ziehen lassen.
Ich habe auch äh ich habe auch hinweise bekommen und hab einige dann einfach direkt zugemacht.
Die bundeswehr ist ja auf instagram auf insta.
Auf insta.
Und da haben sie retro mode getwittert hast du retro mode gesehen von der bundeswehr hier tim.
Ja hakenkreuz und so.
Kreuz das ist einfach eine wehrmacht uniform,
oh man,
macht's uniform twittern als deutsche bundeswehr mit einem fetten hakenkreuz noch drauf zwei sogar und dem eisernen kreuz,
und dann haben sie noch irgendwie so 'n sticker dran gemacht retro.
Ich mache auf retro auf insta.
Wir sehen in diesem land ja der brain der schlägt echt langsam durch so.
Na ja gut ich meine hast du jetzt wieder irgendein social media manager ja und die leute sind ja auch nicht zu beneiden.
Und die verrennen sich dann halt also ich finde es auch ein bisschen schwierig.
Also wie kannst du dich denn so verrennen.
Zu sagen du leute können sich verbrennen verbrennen sich einfach weil sie nicht ausreichend gebildet sind.
Verrennen sich bis stalingrad.
Ja sag mal so ich hab ein bisschen schwierigkeiten so 'n twitteraccount selbst in der bundeswehr draufsteht.
Automatisch auch gleich mit die bundeswehr gleichzusetzen,
klar ist es irgendwie unangemessen und es gehört auch sein gelassen und so weiter aber ich kann es nicht sagen oh,
die bundeswehr zeigt ihr wahres gesicht so ja weil das ist dann geht dann dann doch ein bisschen übers ziel hinaus.
Die bundeswehr hatte unter der alten verteidigungsministerin die ja jetzt kommissionspräsident hin.
Werden möchte oder ist das schon ist jetzt schon.
Dann ist eigentlich nochmal ja.
Die hat ja eine sich da sehr viel streit mit der mit den general und so eingehandelt als sie gesagt hat passt mal auf euer helden kult hier mit den,
mit den nazi general und so da müsste man jetzt langsam mit aufhören es kann sein dass sie von alleine erst übermorgen kommen sie uns präsidentin wird ich glaube der junge ist noch bis sonntag.
Da fragt man sich ja schon also irgendjemand bei der bundeswehr da gesessen hat auch noch diesen diesen retro sticker da drauf gemacht ja das das ist ja nicht so dass irgendjemand.
Sein insta aus der tasche geholt die uniform und gesagt hat ja hier seine hand ein spruch da waren grafik männchen dran ja und hat dann da irgendwie retro sticker,
und hier retro mode hält sich auch bei der bundeswehr und kein mensch ist auf die idee gekommen dass das eine wehrmacht uniform ist das ist schon.
Erstaunlich aber ich bin ja auch sowieso meine meine position dass das mit dem wehrpflicht abschaffen keine gute idee war hören ja auch viele nicht so gerne.
Aber dann hast du halt gar keine männer.
Ja es ist äh in der tat ein problem wenn wenn die bundeswehr nicht mehr so sehr vom querschnitt der bevölkerung gestritten wird.
Ich also ich weiß da haben viele leute bestimmte ansichten zu
ich hätte auch keine zehn pferde hätten mich zur bundeswehr bekommen aber mein zivildienst war auf gar keinen fall ein verlorenes ja in meinem leben das war eine vollkommen
wunderbare sache vielleicht vollkommen in ordnung.
Ich glaube die bundeswehr würde er nach zehn pferde mobilisieren um dich da schnell wieder weg zu bekommen.
Ich ich glaube ich glaube ich sag mal das wäre wahrscheinlich für beide seiten echt unangenehm geworden wenn ich bei der bundeswehr gewesen wäre.
Ja ich glaube bei mir auch.
Aber da hätte ich also spaß hätte ich da auch nicht dran gehabt.
Ich hab's mir leicht gemacht.
Was hast du gemacht bis nach berlin gegangen.
Ich bin einfach britta geblieben.
Geiler trick oder jetzt bin ich ja deutscher aber komischerweise haben sie mich bisher noch nicht angeschrieben jetzt stehe ich dir ich bin ja in den besten jahren.
Das wird der welt schlicht ausgesetzt.
Ja also das hat sich dann doch schon angeboten sorry aber da hätte ich da will ich halt auch vor die hunde gegangen.
Es tut mir leid konnte konnte nicht zum wer körper beitragen.
So in iran war eine woche das internet weg.
Ziemlich krass,
in iran gibts jetzt also die sanktionen die die usa die situation im iran kriegt jetzt nicht,
vollständig zusammengefasst vor allem nicht als vorletztes thema in der sendung aber die sanktionen die usa da gegen den iran anstrengend die haben natürlich jetzt langsam ihre wirkung die währung ist ungefähr noch die hälfte fährt.
Und das land wird wenn deine währung innerhalb eines jahres ungefähr die hälfte ein wert verliert dann hast du ein problem,
und die regierung hat dann gesagt wir erhöhen die benzin preise was zu massenprotesten im iran geführt hat.
Muss man sagen die benzin preise im iran sind für unsere verhältnisse absurd niedrig.
Klar die haare sind ein bisschen näher dran an dem öl und so ne dann haben das auch glaube ich sowieso stark wird zuschuss auch nochmal ja und jetzt gibt's da halt.
Unruhen.
Und was macht der iran schaltet das internet ab und zwar also ab im prinzip die nach die verbindungen nach außen,
es gab die mund die network monitor sagen sie es ist irgendwie oft auf zwanzig prozent runtergegangen,
kann man auch sehr schön sehen die netz netz konnektivität hier klarer drop ja und da haben wir den echt eine woche lang das internet ausgeschaltet,
und.
Das ist natürlich sehr sehr beängstigend weil das passiert natürlich damit da keine informationen nach draußen bringen können während im deinen zweifelsfall irgendwelche kräfte gegen protestieren vorgehen,
es ist eine äußerst beängstigend die situation und ich man kann nur hoffen dass das,
massive folgen hat also nur mal um das mal ins verhältnis zu setzen,
hier in deutschland hast du irgendwelche präparate sitzen die angst haben dass der strom an tag ausfällt ne,
aber dass der eigene staat die kommunikations verbindungen ins ausland gehabt damit du da damit kein insta gemacht wird und kein twitter,
und die journalistinnen und journalisten ihre nachrichten nicht nach hause bekommen das ist halt eine ein terroristische akt gegen das eigene volk,
das ist durch nichts zu entschuldigen.
Ja wir hatten ja auch in der letzten sendung glaube ich auch die pläne russlands jetzt das internet quasi soweit
um zu strukturieren um eben genau solche maßnahmen letzten endes auch durchführen zu können da natürlich nicht dass das das ziel ist aber das wird natürlich dann die folge davon sein china macht's vor der rest macht's nach,
gerade ist auch ganz weit vorne ich könnte können eigentlich jetzt schon eine notiz machen.
Bis jetzt hier irgendwie die erste person für deutschland das auch fordert wegen der sicherheit.
Naja wird so schnell nicht stattfinden.
Rainer wendt wird das schon was zu einfallen,
so die restlichen themen nehmen wir mit in die nächste sendung,
dass wir hier zu lang und eigentlich jetzt auch noch ein dankes blog den mache ich dann auch mit in den nächsten sind und wir können jetzt eher überlegen ob wir es überhaupt noch mal schaffen tim vom,
sechsunddreißig zwei drei nochmal eine sendung zu machen.
Das überlegen wir mal bei mir sieht es ganz gut aus aber ich weiß du bist noch deutlich mehr eingespannt und von daher lassen wir das jetzt hier einfach mal offen.
Wir haben den wir haben den sechsten im kalender das könnte klappen sollte es eigentlich,
vielleicht können vielleicht schaffen wir es sogar zwei sendungen davor drei.
Sogar zwei na ja bei drei ja nee das ist glaube ich unwahrscheinlich.
Aber der kongress läuft alle tickets sind verkauft das motto ist glaube ich bekannt.
Hast du noch eins zu verschenken dein ticket.
Ah überlege ich mir mal noch überlege ich mir tatsächlich noch stimmt eigentlich ich verschenke eigentlich jedes jahr ein ticket an eine,
unterrepräsentiert eine einen mitglied einer unterrepräsentiert gruppe.
Ja dann mach ich das mach ich wieder und zwar kontaktformular gibt's auf meiner website,
wer ein ticket geschenkt haben möchte meldet sich bitte,
und zwar werde ich das aber diesmal eisenhardt nach wer sich als erstes dort meldet machen weil die auswahl zu treffen ist jedes jahr sehr schmerzhaft.
Mainz ist schon weg.
Das ist.
Der nichts zu schreiben ist gerade nochmal nachgeschaut aber,
ich habe glaube ich jetzt die entsprechende person die der beschreibung entspricht gefunden gut das wars leute.
Ne ich wollte eigentlich ein bisschen was über den kongress erzählen.
Ach so du weißt doch was man kongress erzählt ah aua.
Das motto der das motto des kongress ist resource ja eben haben wir alles noch nicht gesagt.
Es stimmt das haben wir alles noch gar nicht besprochen das ist ja das ist ja das ist ja.
Und der fahrplan ist quasi fertig kommt jetzt bald.
Und das wird auch alles es wird ein großer spaß werden ja extra versucht hier regelmäßig auf kongress vorträge bezug zu nehmen die da noch kommen werden das ist 'ne spannende sache.
Das war schon was zu sagen wolltest.
Ja du klickst da so wild auf dem computer rum dann glaube ich du willst gar nicht mehr im kongress reden.
Doch gerne ich wollte ich nur in deinem rede fluss jetzt nicht.
Nee wir schaffen noch eine sendung vom kongress und dann reden wir darüber ich bin jetzt müde.
Genau und wir haben es auch schon zwei stunden zusammen also leute es geht noch ein bisschen weiter dieses jahr und von daher sag mal erstmal tschüs bis bald.
Aux